right now the left actually is quite  United these voices that I've always  said are relatively small in terms of  power they're very loud but they're  relatively small  um that do the Purity tests and the  litmus tests they are not getting nearly  the attention that they once did and  overall the left is pretty damn United  right now I think that it's critical at  a time when the right is splintering and  sub splintering and sub splintering at  infinitum hopefully  um that the left uh maintained focused  on the big issues that we are trying to  deal with that includes getting people  Health Care dealing with inequality  um help climate there's so many I don't  even know what order to go the education  crisis the foreign policy embarrassments  that plagued this under Trump on and on  and on the left has an opportunity to in  contrast to what's happening on the  right look quite organized and sane and  United